Let's discuss the solution for our branch prediction performance quiz.
The first thing we want to do is figure out how many cycles are we
spending per iteration of this loop in the case where we
are fetching nothing until we are sure what to fetch. There is a trick to this.
Which is when we fetch the ADDI here we don't know if it is a branch.
So we are not sure what to fetch in the next cycle. When the ADDI moves to
the decode stage at the end of that cycle we know that it's not a branch. So
actually the ADDI's costs us two cycles. One to fetch it and
then there is a pipeline bubble untill we can decode it. Similarly, the add
costs us two cycles. One to fetch it, one to be sure that it's not a branch.
For a branch, we fetch it in once cycle, we decode it in the next cycle,
we're still not sure what to fetch, because now that we know it's a branch,
we need to know whether it's taken or not. So the branch costs us three cycles.
When the branch is in the earlier stage we have two pipeline bubbles
already because we wouldn't fetch anything yet. And only after that,
we know what to fetch. So there are three cycles worth of branch and
doing nothing before we can fetch the next instruction. So
overall, we're spending seven cycles per iteration of this loop.
Now let's see what happens with a perfect predictor.
With a perfect predictor, when we are fetching the ADD,
we can perfectly predict that the next instruction to fetch is this second ADD.
So we spend one cycle here, one cycle here, and with a perfect predictor once we
have fetched this branch we magically know that we should be fetching this ADDI.
So we spend one cycle here for a total of three cycles. So the speed up of
having a perfect predictor, in this case, is 7 over three, which is 2.33.
So with a perfect predictor, we would have more than twice the performance than
we're having when fetching nothing until we are sure what to fetch.